بدون صوت
[موسيقى]
لا شيء يعكس حجما نفوذ بقدري هذا المشهد
اناشيد ايرانيه على الى اراضي العراقيه
واين في نصب الشهيد اوسطه بغداد رمزيه
الاكبر له تاريخ العراق المرتبط
به مع ايران
شيدا في الثمانينات ابان الحرب تخليدا
لذكرى جنود العراقيين والمفارقه تكمن في
ان عدوى الامس بات بطل اليوم
حارب ضد العراق
في نصف الشهيد العراقي
بين بغداد
اما الواضح اليوم سيطره ايرانيه عبر فصائل
مواليه في العراق وصور نفوذه المتعدده
شيده هذا النصف اذا
الحرب وذلك تخليدا للجنود العراقيين والان
هو للمفارقه
تاتي من كل
عفوا نعم اخطات في الموقع اذا اسبوع
الشهاده والسياده نظمه الحشد واعتبرها
العراقيون استفزازا هذه رمزيه شوهت لكن
الواضح اليوم سيطر ايرانيه على فصائل
مواليه في العراق والنفوذ صوره المتعدده
نعم انها الهيمنه الايرانيه